[Música]
a formação criação e educação são
palavras que sempre nortearam minha vida
e minha carreira e que lugar melhor para
falar sobre isso que a universidade é um
prazer estar aqui com vocês eu sou
fascinado por tecnologia e olha quando
digo fascinada de verdade eu sou nerd
pelo menos era assim que os garotos do
colégio gritava enquanto corriam atrás
de mim eu sou nerd até hoje falam isso
de mim eu não sei bem se pela minha
coleção de comics
ou talvez pela minha coleção de
videogames ou de rubik's mas eu tenho
alguma suspeita que é devido um storm
trooper tamanho real que eu tenho no meu
escritório dentro de um aquário
então ele fica olhando para a porta tem
uma luz em cima dele
então quando eu entro passo na frente da
porta ele olha pra mim o olho pra ele e
ele me disse mentalmente o que você está
fazendo aí fora que não está estudando
eu escuto isso mais ninguém porque eu
testei então não se preocupem fiquem
tranquilos
eu sempre adorei tecnologia sempre
adorei tecnologia e principalmente nas
questões vinculadas à a a programação
sempre gostei muito dessa área a
linguagem dos computadores e eu acabei
me formando em programação aos 15 anos
de idade quando eu fiz o primeiro curso
para entender esse mecanismo eu sempre
adorei isso trabalhei muito nessa área
durante a minha vida inteira e atua até
hoje como professor em várias áreas
nesse aspecto tecnologia é a minha
paixão
dentro dessa área de formação pode
provar por favor nós temos ali algumas
coisas que eu preciso levar em
consideração que vocês existem três
grandes passos que eu posso citar pra
vocês que nos trouxe até onde estamos
hoje e eu não vou falar aqui da questão
cronológica tá eu vou falar da questão
que me importa mais que pra mim é mais
importante
o primeiro ponto é a criação da internet
aliás completa
desde a primeira conexão entre redes
conecta vai completar agora 50 anos na
próxima terça feira então já tem uma
certa idade não é verdade e com a
internet isso é um grande sonho
aquele sonho que encheu o coração das
pessoas
em 1969 que era a possibilidade de todo
conhecimento da humanidade está disposto
ou não de todo mundo era um grande sonho
depois veio o celular
o celular é mais antigo a primeira
junção das tecnologias que
possibilitaram um celular se deu mais ou
menos há 63 anos atrás aliás completou
63 anos agora em outubro também o
celular
ele trouxe com ele ou muitas
possibilidades
muitas possibilidades e logo depois essa
terceira grande passo também pra falar
pra vocês reunião das duas tecnologias
do celular e da internet
a primeira possibilidade que nós tivemos
comercial de um aparelho que deu a
possibilidade de levar a conexão celular
através de um dispositivo móvel tem 23
anos apenas perceba apenas 23 anos
eu estou falando de 63 anos o celular 50
anos de todas as questões vinculadas à
internet mas eu estou falando apenas de
23 anos da questão do smartphone ou seja
dos da conexão através do celular
lembre se o celular antigamente quando
ele foi elaborado ele pesava 40 quilos
então surge o celular 23 anos
provavelmente a idade de muitos dos
senhores que estão aqui e desde esse
tempo muita coisa evoluiu exatamente
isso extremamente evoluindo
principalmente o peso evoluiu diminua
muito ao contrário do meu nesses 23 anos
mas principalmente na adesão das pessoas
a este equipamento
perceba nós estamos falando mais ou
menos hoje em 3 bilhões de pessoas com
smartphones isso em números com
servidores porque já existe em pesquisa
afirmando que somos quatro bilhões de
pessoas com smartphones no mundo têm
idéia do tamanho desse público o como
importante isso 4 bilhões de pessoas com
uma idéia 4 bilhões de pessoas
é mais ou menos metade da população do
mundo
vamos lá pegar a média dos 3 bilhões e 4
bilhões mais ou menos metade da
população do mundo e toda essa questão
vinculada um smartphone trouxe uma
várias perspectivas né
várias coisas que nós devemos pensar e
principalmente entender como isso
funciona hoje
aliás fiquei muito feliz que escutei
muitas das coisas que eu vou falar hoje
aqui nesses momentos que a gente tá
fazendo inicialmente na questão da
informação também o smartphone trouxe
com ele algumas possibilidades
perceba esse celular smartphone quando
surgiu ele ea gente não percebe isso
mas o celular o que nós temos hoje no
bolso no ataque desligado
ele tem a mesma tecnologia ou seja a
tecnologia superior ao que foi
necessário para levar o homem à lua ea
gente não percebe isso
ou seja nesse momento nós temos um
universo de alta tecnologia conectada e
portátil possível no nosso bolso
depois nós temos outras questões
por favor a desinformação
essa realidade e esse sonho o sonho do
universo conectado e portátil ea
realidade de um universo conectado e
portátil não veio de forma isolada
ela vem acompanhado de alguns efeitos
colaterais digamos assim esses efeitos
colaterais são extremamente importantes
você compreender perceba nasceu o
celular
nós temos a conexão nós temos todas as
questões da da internet na mão do
celular
esses efeitos colaterais
o cérebro a possibilidade de informações
que não são reais
ouvi falar disso sobre onde é hoje aqui
nós não podemos e todo mundo sabe que
não podemos acreditar em tudo o que está
na internet
sim muitas coisas que não podem ser
creditados que estão lá não é verdade
ok é principalmente quando eu falo em
questões de redes sociais
e eu não falo em rede social pensando os
que ela é a principal delas mas pela
tamanho que ela adquiriu nos últimos
tempos
imagine o seguinte nós temos no brasil
hoje mais ou menos 6.6 é 66% da
população conectada em rede social
se você tirar os jovens e tirar os
idosos um meio que são os adultos
representam 50%
imagine o quão poderoso é uma rede
social
naquele público 66% imagine o quão
importante é um público que é
economicamente ativo e politicamente
ativo então nós temos uma série de
coisas importantes para tratar ali que
são coisas em que me interessam na
questão da sua possibilidade então as
redes sociais vieram tem todas essas
questões principalmente de desinformação
né
eu sei que vocês têm algumas idéias
dentro da internet principalmente nas
questões vinculadas ao celular vocês
viram vocês têm acesso
vocês sabem que não podem acreditar em
tudo que está ali dentro e com certeza
vocês sabem conseguem ver isso com
clareza dentro de filmes dentro de
publicações dentro de histórias entre
inúmeras outras coisas que estão dentro
desse contexto não é principalmente nas
questões que são relativas às coisas que
são publicadas nesses meios que não
condizem com a realidade que não tem a
ver com aquilo que realmente é de fato
eo impacto que isso pode ter as pessoas
e desenvolver certas conceito que não
são reais
imagine a 50 anos atrás nós estamos
perplexos
as possibilidades de todo o conhecimento
da humanidade está disponível para o ser
humano para todos os seres humanos
hoje 50 anos depois quando você abre uma
rede social o que você vê a discussão
por exemplo se a terra é plana e é
verdade
perceba o quanto ela veio eo quanto ela
trouxe de problema então nesse momento
começam a nascer os problemas de uma
universo de alta tecnologia conectada e
portátil e agora eu vou para ti aqui pra
o assunto é mais vinculada à minha área
de atuação principalmente na área
acadêmica e que me traz uma certa
preocupação e eu vou tentar aqui
conversar com vocês
quais são essas questões quantos de
vocês aqui conhecem alguém que deitado
na cama após um dia de trabalho
exaustivo mexendo no celular
você sabe como funciona deitado e com o
passar do tempo a mão começa a formigar
você não sente mais a mão e de repente
os celulares correr que bate bem no meio
do nariz
quantos de vocês aqui isso já aconteceu
levanta a mão pra mim por favor
exatamente imagine o seguinte
ainda bem que não estamos em 1956 porque
senão ia pesar 40 quilos né
graças a deus e qual é a primeira coisa
que as pessoas fazem quando isso
acontece
vence a película não quebrou esse é um
clássico
de modo algum missão clara tem que ver é
uma característica nós
a segunda questão que é importante falar
com vocês é outra é essa que vocês
conhecem alguém ou se tem no seu círculo
de amizades
é uma pessoa que a primeira coisa que
faz quando acorda pegar no celular
quando aqui fazem isso por favor vocês
conhecem alguém que põe o relógio pode
despertar um pouco antes para poder ter
cinco minutos a mais para poder mexer no
celular
levanta a mão aqui pra ninguém faz isso
ok estamos vendo que tem muita gente
aqui
outra questão importante também quem
aqui com o celular no bolso fazendo uma
atividade
de complexa pegou o celular para ver que
horas eram
e quando percebeu tinham passado duas
horas daquele momento você desliga o
telefone e continua sem saber que horas
são
levanta a mão pra mim exatamente para
compreender isso eu preciso passar para
vocês algumas informações principalmente
aquelas relativas à a agressividade
competitiva do mundo moderno
e esse é um tema que é bem interessante
é infelizmente pt talvez não consiga
passar aqui com toda a propriedade que
mereça esse assunto mas agressividade
competitiva do mundo moderno
nada mais é que as empresas de modo
geral viram nesse universo
principalmente as grandes corporações
viram nesse universo de alta tecnologia
conectada e portátil uma grande
oportunidade a oportunidade de ouro para
que eles pudessem entrar no mercado de
forma eficiente
perceba pra que também as empresas
percebendo essa oportunidade entrando
nessa oportunidade a agressividade
competitiva do mundo moderno colocando
as empresas uma grande oportunidade para
elas
buscando acima de tudo conquistar a sua
atenção e não só conquistar a sua
atenção reter a sua atenção pelo maior
tempo possível
percebe que hoje é mais ou menos assim
com que a internet funcione o celular
não é só conquistar a atenção do público
mas reter pelo maior tempo possível esse
público retendo ele mantendo ele
chamando a atenção dele é mais ou menos
assim que funciona a agressividade
competitiva do mundo moderno
ela tenta reter você o mais tempo
possível dentro dela
portanto as empresas olhando a sua
oportunidade e colocando esse ps essa
questão vinculada em tentar abraçar o
maior passo possível aaa assim as
pessoas e trazê-los para dentro do seu
contato e reter a atenção delas elas
fizeram isso de forma muito eficiente
não só conquistando mas lembrando que
hoje
a atenção vale muito dinheiro a atenção
do consumidor hoje valeu muito dinheiro
e ela não é só aplicada a essa questão é
aplicada para toda a sociedade de modo
geral hoje em dia o serviço em várias
áreas e de uma forma muito específica
porque antigamente era aplicada para as
massas de forma uniforme e hoje não é
assim é extremamente personalizada
indivíduo por indivíduo a o celular
consegue fazer isso então a forma de
chamar a atenção e reter a atenção do
sérgio é diferente da forma de chamar a
atenção e reter a atenção do eduardo
josé do tiago da ana
então essa forma toda faz com que os o
celular tem uma eficiência muito grande
ela transporta consigo uma eficiência
muito complexa e ele está presente
dentro de todo celular todo celular tem
essa agressividade competitiva do mundo
moderno e nós damos esse celular hoje a
criança de 4 anos de idade então tem uma
preocupação aqui para ser observada
outro ponto é que é aaa a riqueza de
informação gera pobreza de atenção
saibam já disse isso há muito tempo né
e os especialistas dizem hoje que a
tensão é mais importante mais escasso
recurso econômico porque as empresas
querem chamar a atenção reter a atenção
do consumidor quanto mais melhor
para se tornar o que irresistível para
ele quanto mais irresistível formais
contato ele vai ter comigo isso tem
vários problemas e você consegue ver
isso em várias situações
com certeza vocês já viram isso em
propagandas em no seu celular você já se
deu contra de por exemplo é feito ninhos
de red lines poderosas que não tem nada
a ver com o conteúdo
vocês já viram fotos chamativas para
chamar a sua atenção em reter a sua
atenção no máximo você vê isso com
clareza em vários aspectos do que nós
temos hoje na sociedade e de modo geral
isso tem várias conseqüências
outro ponto importante outro ponto
importante
é quem enviou a o celular virou um
grande buraco negro de atenção
esse buraco negro de atenção e tem tudo
pra ele que tem tudo pra ele então o que
acontece
a atenção é finita por natureza e ela
acaba se esgotando com o tempo e as
pessoas não têm tempo para fazer as
outras coisas
nesse momento eu tenho duas coisas muito
importantes pra falar e terminando já a
primeira delas é a questão que tem a ver
com um dos assuntos parte nem diz ao uso
do celular dentro de sala de aula por
exemplo vamos lá um primeiro ponto o
celular
ele está hoje no bolso de todo mundo e
possivelmente ele vai estar dentro da
sala de aula
portanto o professor tem que saber que o
conteúdo que vai apresentar tem cestão
chamativo e tão é importante que chama a
atenção dele porque senão ele vai correr
o risco de perder a atenção para o
celular
alguns podem dizer mas sérgio essa
guerra perdida não tem como ganhar essa
guerra com o celular eu digo que sim
essa possibilidade mas a estrutura de
como constrói o conteúdo de como se
apresenta o conteúdo tem que ser
modificada porque senão você vai acabar
perdendo essa atenção do aluno é
possível sim pegar a essa estrutura
tecnológica que foi estipulada e trazer
para dentro mas nós vamos ter que
evoluir isso eu tenho certeza que é
possível usar esse universo de alta
tecnologia conectada e portátil a favor
da educação e da formação dos nossos
jovens
é isso roque muito obrigada
ae